there were six singularities then the
universe exploded into existence and the
remnants of these systems were forged
into concentrated ingots infinity stone
hey everybody it's Charlie Marvel has
been doing a lot of press recently
because of the Captain Marvel movie in
the Oscars Kevin Feige did a new
interview where he explained a whole
bunch of details about the Eternals
movie which is like one of the next
really big brand new franchises during
Marvel phase four so we'll break it down
we're still doing the IMAX ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment
about Marvel phase 4 on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this
this is Kevin Feige official statement
about avengers endgame spider-man far
from home Marvel phase 4 in the Eternals
movie this is mostly about how the
Eternals fit into the MCU timeline so he
says everything after endgame and
everything after spider-man far from
home will be different and be unique
although technically it's the end of
Avengers endgame that's changing the
Marvel Cinematic Universe in a really
significant way in spider-man far from
home is the first Marvel phase 4 movie
is gonna still feel very much like a
classic spider-man film so it won't be
quite as different as the other Marvel
phase 4 films but then he goes on saying
but seeing returning characters is
certainly something we're gonna do and
want to do he's talking about the phase
1 Avengers coming back like all the
characters that you're wondering about
maybe some will die maybe some will live
I've already done a couple videos
discussing this because probably only
one character is gonna die and most of
them will eventually come back then
Kevin Feige goes on saying but also
introducing characters that the majority
of the world has never heard of much
like the guardians much like the
Avengers before we made the Avengers and
there are lots of them Eternals are one
group but we like that idea of
introducing an ensemble doing an
ensemble movie from the start as opposed
to building it up as the way we did with
the first Avengers movie more like the
Guardians not totally but in terms of
introducing a new group of people you
were asking about the 60s and the 70s
before Jack Kirby did an immense amazing
epic with the Eternals that spans tens
of thousands of years and that's
something that we haven't really done
which is why that among many other
things post Avengers endgame we find
appealing so this way he seems really
excited about eternals because like the
Guardians they're a very obscure group
of comic book characters that very few
people know about
even among hardcore Marvel comic book
fans the Eternals are really really nice
group but like what is the last time you
heard modern big mainstream Marvel comic
book characters in the comics talk about
hanging out with the Eternals characters
they did appear recently they tried to
sort of clean up some of the continuity
because it's very confusing so already
in Kevin Feige statement he talks about
10,000 years so he's sort of compressing
the timeline of the turtles in the MCU a
little bit so I'll explain what's going
on
the Eternals characters come from the
Celestials the Celestials are some of
the earliest living beings in the
universe or the multiverse itself so
just early timeline of the MCU right now
as we know it the timeline does not
start with the Big Bang it actually
predates that there was a previous
version of the universe that suffered
heat death so that version of the
universe collapses and then re expands
in another Big Bang out of that Big Bang
the remnants of that previous universe
become the Infinity stones that's why
they're so powerful they contain the
power of an entire universe distilled
into small stones simultaneously when
that happens a new version of eternity
is born so eternity is sort of like the
soul the cosmic entity that is the life
force of the entire multiverse so it's
so vast that you can barely comprehend
it that's why Peter quill looks so
trippy there when he says he can see
everything he sees eternity all of
existence that's how vast it is one of
eternity Dee's first acts was to create
the Celestials and task them with
gardening the universe then come back on
millions and billions of years later to
see what had become of their experiment
just like a garden you try to grow
things you pull the weeds out when you
need to Galactus technically isn't a
celestial but the MCU might turn him
into a celestial once they get all those
Fantastic Four x-men characters he's one
of those cosmic weed pullers so when the
Celestials came to Planet Earth they
created the Eternals experimenting on
human life and then later in the comics
they would come back to visit but they
were always viewed as sort of
antagonistic characters the Eternals
themselves were so advanced and powerful
and long-lived that the humans on earth
did evolve treated them like gods they
would actually confuse them with the
actual Greek gods of the Marvel Universe
because most of them lived in Olympia
which existed right at the nexus between
our dimension and the dimension where
the Greek gods lived it got really
confusing they had their own Wars they
got Barry Game of Thrones II you have
the deviance which is sort of like
genetic offshoots of them they had their
own civil wars groups of them left earth
and colonized other planets like Titan
that eventually became the place where
Thanos was born so Thea knows is an
eternal in the MCU
but because the comics say that that
happened about 5 million years ago when
the Eternals first rose in Kevin Feige
is talking more like 10,000 years
obviously they're probably gonna
simplify a lot of that history for the
Marvel Cinematic Universe just there's a
common point of history between
different franchises black panthers
actually a really good example because
their history goes way way back tens of
thousands of years but if you style
yourself an anthropologist of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe think about it this
way what's really important and happened
around 10,000 years ago around 10,000
years ago in real life history is where
you see the beginnings of modern
civilization written history in the
transition of humans to more urban
societies as opposed to more nomadic
hunter-gatherer communities also talking
about fictional MCU history around
10,000 years ago is when Bush anga
became the first Black Panther we have
that opening scene of the Black Panther
movie where they narrate the history of
the world from the perspective of all
Condon's
so around 10,000 years ago you have the
rise of bashang guy he eats the
heart-shaped herb which grew in
vibranium tainted soil that gives him
the ability to communicate with past the
Panther God giving him his powers and
leading to the rise of what became
modern-day Wakanda but I think what
happened in reality within the history
of the MCU is that the vibranium
meteorite crashed long before that and
it took a little while for the vibranium
to leach into the soil and to start to
grow the arch shaped
herb which eventually led to bashang
getting powers but you can see the fun
of tieing the rise of the Eternals to
the rise of the Black Panther line now
just to be clear vibranium does not come
from the Celestials unless they want to
change that for the MCU the vibranium
meteorite is a completely separate idea
they haven't said anything special about
including black panther stuff during the
Eternals movie I dressed a little bit of
this in my recent Captain Marvel trailer
video last week where I talked a little
bit about Easter eggs for her origin
story that tie her to the other Avengers
characters in present day without the
characters necessarily realizing it I'll
talk more about it
I do Easter eggs for that movie but at
the end of the day it makes sense that
they want to link these characters so
Eternals in black panther have a sort of
common history tying it to present-day
Thanos of Titan is an eternal his father
was the son of one of the original
Eternals but you have to imagine that
they're all extremely long-lived just
like as Guardians as Guardians lived to
about 5,000 years old give or take a
little bit so Thea knows is older than
Thor but he's much younger than Odin the
main cast of the Jack Kirby comics are
supposed to be the main cast of the
movie they're also featured a lot in the
miniseries so usually it's the same
group of characters that pop up over and
over but it's Cersei Icarus who's sort
of like the leader of their younger
group of eternals Gilgamesh Macari
Alicia's thena xerus who's actually
Icarus his father in apparently starfox
is rumored to be in the movie even
though he's Thanos his brother in the
comics I don't know how they're gonna
explain him in the MCU and if it's gonna
be different he won't be related to
Thanos or how they'll try to tie them
together but the main villain is
supposed to be drew aghh who's Icarus is
uncle he's also another eternal Thanos
is not listed in the cast but Josh
Brolin is like I would love to come back
and do an eternal movie they're supposed
to be doing a trilogy if everything
works out so maybe in one of those
sequel movies we can see a young version
of Thanos be born because remember if
these characters are tens of thousands
of years old and Thanos is only 2,000
years old you'd have to have a couple
really big-time jumps before he's born
there hasn't been any mention of the
deviance so I don't know how the movie
is going to invoke them maybe they'll
just canonize them as being eternals
with genetic abnormalities or an
underclass of some point but just
remember that the way the guardians were
introduced is it was sort of a
self-contained movie that had links to
Planet Earth and things happening in
modern-day but really it was kind of
separate off by itself so I'm expecting
the first eternals movie to be very
similar where you meet these characters
and there's like a couple Easter eggs
for things that are happening in present
day but for the most part you just see
these characters in their corner of the
MCU before you see them start to
crossover in later movies with other
modern-day characters because extremely
long-lived of course a couple of them
would probably live in present day when
things are happening during Avengers
infinity war in Avengers endgame if you
really liked how guardians was super
weird compared to the other phase 1
phase 2 movies
I'm sure the Eternals will be even
weirder so it should be really cool
whatever it ends up looking like do not
be surprised if we get some concept art
in more official news from Marvel during
their phase 4 panel at comic-con later
this summer really good trailer watch
news there's gonna be a new trailer for
x-men Dark Phoenix later this week is
supposed to drop at a really weird time
when it does I will totally make a video
as long as you have alerts enabled for
my channel you'll see the video there
will be other trailers for different
movies so just leave all your video
requests in the comments below
congratulations Mike Hawk you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
my channel so I can get your details
click here for my early non-spoilery
Captain Marvel movie review and click
here for my brand-new Game of Thrones
season 8 trailer video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]